herzlich zu einer neuen folge ich fahre
leute und herzlich willkommen auch an
meinen heutigen gast ich freue mich sehr
jeremy fragrance was geht mit seinem
ferrari lauter als der auspuff 458
italia
[Musik]
kommt aber warum leute kommt an warum
war froh über all das pferdchen hier
cavallino rampante heißt das ding geil
hier sind richtig das ist keine folie
das ist so richtig solbakken hier nahm
die goldene rolex watch ferrari number
one ich hab's immer bock number one zu
sein also mag ich mich auch gern mit
dingen identifizieren die in ihrer
disziplin number one sind roter ferrari
und dann noch sauger 570 ps
ihr könnt dann verschiedene rennfahrer
fragen die sagen ich alle das ist
affengeil und jetzt nicht die die immer
neue rauskommen auch wenn ich ferrari
liebe aber ich finde die produzieren ein
bisschen zu viel im moment alles turbo
und wenn es jetzt neue aktien und jaja
und nicht mehr pininfarina jahres noch
tief erina designer kommen warum leute
hier seht ihr es auch hier verringert
ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz bekannter
designer ja auch verewigt er hat den
wagen auch entwickelt wir sehen hier das
erkennt ja an diesem musterungen du hast
hier keramikbremsen minimal minimal
tiefer gelegt und minimal die spur
verbreitert das sieht man hier das war
so dieser service links booms und
affengeil weil das soll nicht als sie
aussehen
aber wenn er so minimal tiefer ist und
minimal breiter so geil das kombiniert
mit dem sound ist kommt irgendwann herum
leute wir haben hier wie man zum
beispiel auch vom hurrikan kennen einen
motor der hinter dem fahrgast sitzt oder
den fahrgästen rote zylinderköpfe und
der sound ist wirklich einfach affengeil
das ist absolut geisteskrank viereinhalb
liter v8 sauger 75 ps dreht bis 9000
9000 gt3 rs zum beispiel aus und
drehzahl monster vielen der dreht glaub
ich bis achteinhalb 9000 ist rang 5 v8
sehr sehr sehr geil hat michael
schumacher mitteln vor gelten michael
schumacher hat den mitentwickelt und die
werden da ich feststellen da ist auch so
ein federungs knopf drin war ihr weiches
fahren ich habe den bei der testfahrt
gefragt wieso ist das jetzt so und er
sagte mir der der ingenieur von ferrari
ja der michael schumacher der mochte ist
immer weich zu vermehrter kein bock rum
zu springen also ganz coole sache wir
müssen ab diesem jahr müssen leute wie
fans los und ja das steuer von diesem
wunderschönen ferrari gehen
ein kurzes schaut an den sponsor von dem
heutigen video ich bin ja für diese ich
fahre videos immer sehr viel in
deutschland unterwegs hat der viel
höhere kosten als bei meinen vorherigen
videos und wir deswegen sehr froh über
unterstützer von der unterstützer des
heutigen videos ist klar clark hat auch
für euch jetzt gerade eine geile aktion
am laufen deswegen bleibt unbedingt bis
zum ende von diesem staat da leute ich
lese habe ich immer ganz viele
kommentare bekommen auf fragen von
meinen freunden produziert hier autos
die 200.000 euro kosten wie jeremy
ferrari was ist da eigentlich mit dem
thema versicherung da zeigt sich dass
das thema ein sehr wichtiges thema ist
weil ich natürlich auch nicht wenn
irgend etwas blödes passiert im
einsteiger auf der straße liegt dass ich
dann hin privat insolvenz gehen muss
wegen so einem video ich habe mein bild
von angewendet ich bin selbst schon klar
kunde verwendet die app auch das ganze
funktioniert so ihr nehmt eure
bestehenden versicherungsverträge pflegt
die dann in die klage ein und dann sagt
euch dieser intelligente algorithmus
auch die konditionen von diesem vertrag
gut fertig sind oder ob er vielleicht
die gleichen leistung noch günstiger
bekommen könnt ihr seht jetzt hier auf
dem bildschirm ich habe zum beispiel
eine privathaftpflicht jetzt hier über
klar gelaufen privathaftpflicht übrigens
auch sehr wichtiges thema sollte man auf
jeden fall auch aber man kann mit der
app noch viel mehr mache also ich nur
bestehende verträge ein fliegen sondern
auch weiß was ich unten einen bedarf
check machen also welche versicherung
brauche ich eigentlich in meinem leben
wo man bekommt zum beispiel auch hier
auf diesem reiter angebote für
verschiedene bereiche wo versicherung
sinnvoll sein können zum beispiel
berufsunfähigkeit wird sich krankenhaus
datum zu weiteren zuvor aber wie gesagt
bei der ganzen aktion ist auch was für
euch dabei und zwar auch für die
österreicher denn klar gibt es auch in
österreich wissen für dann nicht und
auch die österreichischen zuschauer
unter euch können bei dieser aktion
jetzt kommt mit macht und zwar könnt ihr
jetzt auf den ersten link in der
beschreibung kriegen den code s p
verwenden und dann bekommt ihr für jede
von eurem versicherungen die ihr die
klage pflegt einen 15 euro gutschein das
geht bis zu drei versicherung also bis
zu 540 euro amazon gutschein für euch da
drin also nochmal vielen dank an klar
kurs unterstützen dass es mir echt eine
sehr große hilfe leute und jetzt ab ans
steuer
startknopf und tschüss
wow geil geil geil geil geil geil geil
geil das wie gesagt auch weiche
federungs knopf hier und da kannst du
auch über so schotterpisten hier dessen
alter motto das ist ja unglaublich ist
der denn ja ich zeige dir gleich mal ich
fand ihn übrigens immer noch torleute
das ist ja unfassbar also wirklich ich
bin ja schon im hurrikan evo mitgefahren
und das hier ist so komfortabel ja wir
sind ja gerade über kopfsteinpflaster
her
unfassbar ich bin richtig geschockt
alles offen fahrer abgestimmt
du siehst dir das ist keine spielereien
wie bei lamborghini ihr so einen torpedo
knopf und ab geht's klubmeister wir
machen hier alles auf den fahrer
zugeschnitten der blinker als hier die
hupe ist hier norgay leute korrigieren
dass man im kino so sagen wir dazu
wahnsinn 458 italia dann da stets leute
wow wow oder sound ist sogar das geile
ist natürlich auch das nicht
turbogeladenen ist man beim
runterschalten kommt der geilen sound
und ich mochte auch den 430 aber das ist
hier doppel kopplungsanlage und dies
viel weniger anfällig da so wenn man das
auto sich leisten kann ist das
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so teuer im
unterhalt
weil der wertverlust ist nicht bestehen
können wertvolle stück das ist bei
ferrari ist kassel und ja ich habe
kostenlosen service sowieso weil er so
rechts oder der rechts genauso oder
kommt den tunnel
wir dürfen natürlich nicht zu viel gas
geben aber
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja ja ja geil digger geil ist
mega also ich muss sagen ja wirklich
also auch krass wie anders der ist im
vergleich zum zum hofer kann er also der
markant den finde ich viel mehr in your
face sei so khan ist so recht zum
zuhälter breit gepumpt auf testo und der
ferrari des und mafiosi weiße ware also
bisschen so weiß sie was mir an lambo
nicht so gefällt wie ein ferrari sagt
lambo ist ja im prinzip aus hass auf
ferrari entstanden stimmt ja genau ich
etwas auf hass oder auf neid gebaut ist
vielleicht dass es kein gutes fundament
ferrari enzo ferrari hat soweit ich mich
erinnere gemacht um sein land italien
ehre zu erweisen alter schwede zierte
das statement oder das ist krass ist
keine motivation rot und prachtvoll und
so das ist geil alter number ohren
mégane bauern ich habe es fast vergessen
zu fragen die wichtigste und erste frage
ist immer was bedeuten autos für dich
haben jetzt ganz viele kleine vorlage
vielleicht also als kind wollte ich
immer testfahrer werden bei bmw
ich wollte damals gab es schon so dieses
schaltwippen ja so wird es teurer werden
ich glaube da ist einfach nur mal
irgendwie hat schon damals einen teppich
mit autos und so ist normal
aber letztendlich ist ein auto einfach
eine symbolik wie eine uhr und viel mehr
kann man ja nicht haben an accessoires
und das ist einfach so ein bisschen guck
mal das ist ein expressions of myself
ich trage so eine art von anzug ich
träume und das ist mein auto das ist
einfach so weiter
jetzt direkt genommen
eine weiterführung des teils von der
story bei dem auto ist auch was
besonderes weil ich habe den vor zwei
jahren ungefähr angefangen zu
finanzieren
und das war ziemlich teuer naja und dann
habe ich irgendwann nicht mehr halten
können
kurze zeit also zwei jahre später hatte
ich dir denn im prinzip war online
gekauft als ich in miami an meinem
laptop war so sondern echte story und
dann appartements gekauft hast also und
eine tolle symbolik das ist mein vertrag
den ich schon mal hatte gail hatte ich
zwischendurch verkauft geil und wenn du
dir den zurückholt ist natürlich sorgen
also ich bin sehr geflasht das geil
wirklich sehr komfortabel sehr schön
kultiviert auch der klang es nicht so
brutal schön ich mache mal race anja
dann siehst du wie sich
direktförderungen ändert merkt ja und da
und das ist immer noch weiter als der ur
kann ja es ist tipptopp aber mein
kollege der sagte auch der nimmt sein
ferrari nicht jeden tag aus der garage
ja weil man nutzt du es zu sehr aus so
wie du deine freundin sag ich mal
ausnutzen kannst für sex oder oder essen
ausnutzen kann es für den genuss ja und
den nutze ich eigentlich eher wenn ich
mich sozusagen belohnen möchte nach
einem knallharten arbeitstag ja und ich
mich richtig den arsch getreten hat mit
einer fahrrad fahren mit kalt duschen
und training und videos ohne ende und
100 e-mails beantwortet und dann fahre
ich den das ist geil
das weckt dann aber wir kommen wie die
leute ich auch schon
ja ich würde den 7
das ist geil italia leute also ich muss
sagen ich bin mich 2000 fenstern aber
würde fast sagen wenn er dann auch
ferrari also lambo auch mehr geil aber
irgendwie noch mal wechseln also wenn ja
ist wechselt hier gestellt dass man
gerne wenn du machen willst einfach
beide gleichzeitig boomt und dann am
besten parken drücken abgestimmt und
nicht weg was ja kein leerlauf wahlhebel
irene hier gibt es auch nicht viele
knöpfe rückwärts kann mir automatik des
controllings ersten gang gegen es
allemal über rein damit ja okay und ab
geht die linke das halt geil das ist
alles alles am lenkrad die hupe ist auch
am lenkrad also vor allem gehalt außen
gibt zu es ist geil oder es ist sehr
geil
es ist ein roter ferrari bmi
na ja sehr schön bis 9000 drehen das ist
einfach so sexy und wir sind im web mode
also der ist ganz gut und relax und
weiche federung ist echt so ganz relaxed
und der ist wirklich schafft also der
ist überhaupt nicht nervig damit würde
ich auf morgen zu sagen auch gern zur
arbeit fahren weißt du auch nach dem
stressigen tag habe ich wirklich noch
vorhanden ist wie das hier sagte bowden
nervt mich oder sowas ja letztens bin
ich mit dem 300 kilometer am stück
gefahren und da dröhnt ja schon der
schädel und da habe ich mich erinnert
was so ein bekannter schauspieler mal
sagte der flick gern flugzeug war ja
nichts anderes denkt als das fliegen des
flugzeugs weil das voll detention alter
[Musik]
gibt es nichts besseres geil gibt nichts
geileres geil geil geil geil geil auch
nicht die neuen linien richtig schön die
charakteristik auch von den saugmotor
waren sind richtig geil kurzes statement
erklären was sagst du was ich zu den
denn hier werden sehr sehr sehr geil
[Musik]
wunderschön und schön wunderschön die
zeit wird einfach kommen
[Musik]
das ist ja das vorrecht von hirschau
verein ist ja auch michael schumacher
den mitentwickelt mega mega das macht
richtig spaß und alarme und es ist das
ist trotzdem gut so und das kann man
wirklich sagen also gerade noch mal den
darm oder kann auch gefahren ist der
ähnliches konzept ja hat ja auch ein
mittelmotor das ist viel für smoothies
der lambo und im lamborghini meiner
freunde saß da ist mir aufgefallen ist
ein bisschen viel show ist ein bisschen
schade die zeit knapp und so und dann
hochklappen bevor du startest und so was
hast du hier nicht alles auf optimismus
sorry auf of racing at optimale
performance ausgelegt ja beckmann when
you klima review ein automatik und
tschüss wie gibt es nichts weiter hier
zu machen als ich muss sagen lambo ich
gebe benutzer so sprach ich die bilder
lambers und so ein fighter jet und jacht
ist formel 1 das ist ab dass dieses
lenkrad erinnert mich auch giebels ein
formel-1-auto mit diesem modus an hier
unten
sehr sehr sehr sehr geil
[Musik]
geil sehr schön sehr schön dass das
lustige an dem auto ist einer mit dem
180 ps denkst du fährst 300 knallhart
geiles so laut ist man das war ich
alleine weiß ja wie es in irgendeiner
von mir aus klasse ja zu fahren denken
zumal wären mit dem 204 sticks sind dann
ist das schlichtweg ist auch ein
sicherheits features tempo von shift
auch gerade richtung
das fühlt sich das an so sportlich aber
gleichzeitig wie sowieso ein sportlicher
enger anzug
naja das ist nicht so wild ist einfach
diese pro tag in die kurve kurvenlage ja
locker easy
[Applaus]
und der ist so hübsch stehen kannst du
dir ins wohnzimmer stellen so heran
ohne witz wenn du könntest ich würde
ihnen ins wohnzimmer stellen ja da kann
zeit nicht mehr fahren nach hause 2 man
bräuchte so ein haus ist das so eine
plattform hat was aus der gerade der
wagen hochgefahren kann ins wohnzimmer
sein könnte man das machen wir jetzt
hier wirklich absolut katastrophale
straße aber es sehr
das getriebe ist schön weil ich auf
sound treu
wunderschön leute wenn sie darauf jeden
fall der tanz spielen keine also die
km/h anzeige spielt keine große rolle
ganz links im reich der mitte einfach
nur die drehzahlen genau ich bin richtig
schlecht also wirklich das erfahre leute
der wagen ist so sportlich und
gleichzeitig angenehm ja ich habe
gelesen dem 458 italia hat das getriebe
wird der sls trainer zum getragen
getriebe ist das okay und beim sls haben
wir glaube ich viele kritisiert dass der
ein bisschen langsam scheint dabei der
ist unfassbar zackig hier
da ist nix von langsamen top
schaltzeiten da ich muss sagen also das
ja auch ein sauger keine turbolader
leute ja ja ich bin ich dachte ich habe
also ich bin eigentlich ein bisschen so
ein turbo kit so ich mag das wenn der
turbo rein klappt und ich schiebe
ja es ist richtig geil hier geiler
geiler wright leute er ich bin so auch
kein danke der tarif aber gegeben wir
kommen wir zur bewertung leute ja und
die beginnen wir mit der kategorie
aussehen der ferrari 458 italia ist
wirklich eine schönheit aber ich muss
sagen dass so ein kleines detail am
äußeren erscheinungsbild ich weiß nicht
genau was es ist mir so nicht so 100
prozent gefallen vielleicht gefällt
meine persönlichen eindruck dass der
wagen beispielsweise nicht bedeuten
schöner als der porsche von marc gebauer
den 911 gts und deswegen gibt's hier 8
von 10 punkten
dachte ich zumindest im ersten anlauf
dann habe ich mir das material noch mal
angeschaut und damit oder das ding ist
so geil in den verzierten muss die
beschleunigung ist wirklich amtlich und
das auch ohne turbolader null auf
hundert in 3,3 sekunden das ist ganz
knapp an den zehn von zehn vorbei und
gibt folglich 9 von 10 punkten die
coolness ist über jeden zweifel erhaben
das muss man wirklich sagen es ist ein
ferrari und es gibt einfach 10 von 10
punkten ohne die praktikabilität ist
maler großer tank ja relativ großer
front kofferraum ja deswegen gibt es
auch mehr punkte als der hofkammer com
hat der vulkan zwei von zehn bekommen
dem 458 fehlen aber zum beispiel die
rücksitze die die neuen elfer noch
hatten und dementsprechend gibt es hier
drei von cs preis leistungsverhältnis
ist wirklich überraschend gut wie
journey vermeinte der wertverlust ist
praktisch nicht existent für diese
modelle dass es unglaublich
dementsprechend kann man wenn man
entweder reich oder wahnsinnig ist sich
ein solches auto kaufen und mit relativ
wenig wertverlusten kostenlosen
inspektion solange der wagen relativ neu
ist quasi nur für versicherungs und
spritkosten das autofahren auch wenn es
absurd klingt entsprechend viele punkte
hier geben sechs von zehn und
schließlich in punkto komfort der
ferrari ist natürlich nie dafür
ausgelegt geworden besonders
komfortables fahrzeug zu sein aber
gerade im vergleich mit dem hurrikan hat
mich dieser wagen extrem überrascht wie
weit seine federung sein kann ich hatte
echt quasi nie den eindruck von dem auto
genervt zu sein und das bedingt einfach
mehr punkte
deswegen gibt es für den komfort vier
von zehn am ende kommt auf 41 von 60
punkten und auf platz 5 insgesamt was
für einen hardcore sportwagen wie der
ferrari 458 italia einer ist wirklich
eine sehr sehr gute breiten wertung ist
in der spaß wird es damit eine top
platzierung einen geteilten ersten platz
zusammen mit dem 92 turbo s und dem
lamborghini [ __ ] kanebo in der
alltagswelt und dagegen holte ferrari 13
30 punkten und lässt den hörer kanäle
und den i8 deutlich hinter sich
zeitgleich mit dem turbo ist eine sehr
beeindruckende leistung für so ein
scharfes gerät dieses auto hat mich auf
jeden fall zum ferrari fanboy gemacht
leute schreibt eure meinung in die
kommentare und bis zum nächsten sonntag
gemacht gut